What is the best treatment for breast cancer and if one does not want to do chemo?
Well, I picked a loaded last question there.
Well, if the person doesn't want to do chemo, you need to research what else you're going to do.
So, I am not one that is against doing chemotherapy or standards of care in any form diagnosed with any diagnosis.
But you do want to do your research.
One thing I would recommend is sign up for our stop-biting cancer course.
So, we got a ton of information on our cutters clinic website and for $50 our stop-biting cancer is our 3D clause course.
Goes basically over my 600 page book with the same title and has tons of videos on different portal calls that you could use.
Really contact our clinic.
Set up a time to talk to me if you have cancer or if you have an autoimmune disease or if you have anything you need to get more care, immediate care for.
That's called a case review.
It's a couple hundred dollars to do a case review and we'll go over your case and make some clinical decision-making.
I can guide you with some different lab work that you may want to get done to get to that working diagnosis to be able to move forward with a care plan that you feel comfortable with with anything with any disease with any diagnosis you have to feel peace about the decision-making process that you're moving forward with.
I've had patients that felt pressure into doing chemo, they made a decision to do chemo and they didn't want to but there was different pressures that made them make that decision and I told them if you don't change your attitude, I don't think you're going to get the same benefit off this chemo.
Change your attitude that, hey, maybe God wants you to do the chemo and this is going to just work great for you.
I tell you, it makes a big difference in your care plan.
You have to feel peace about the decision-making process that you put yourself in.